hey guys it's Justine and I'm Jenna and
we have another podcast episode can you
believe it that we've worked four
episodes now that's some serious
commitment that we are fulfilling I mean
we got four episodes in three weeks
that's like whoa I don't think I've ever
seen so many YouTube videos I don't
think so either because these who take
it actually way more time than they
thought I was like it'll be just like a
simple fun little what was that so I'm
gonna give you guys a couple little
highlights here from this pause that is
out I'm gonna put a link in the
description or you can check it out you
guys can subscribe I'm so new to podcast
like I don't listen to that many
podcasts I mostly listen to like murder
podcast yeah
dun dun dun so that they can't hear that
this setup is still kind of temporary
we're borrowing some equipment right now
just testing out some different things
to see what will work I'm having so much
fun
that's good that's what life is about is
about sometimes about cool this is a lot
of work to it's fun but it's also work
like people don't realize how much time
and effort goes up to me I mean it
anything well you set up for like three
hours today and Tyler did most of the
work I did a podcast before this for
somebody else and then I came here did
another podcast I am excited about the
long writer of anyway I don't know I'm
gonna be short up saying I need to go
take a nap but let's give us some
highlights from today's podcast episode
rule that Jupiter
hey I'm Justine and I'm Jenna and you're
listening to same brain podcast roll
that intro
[Music]
wasn't that amazing didn't you love that
little girl did you believe it that was
incredible very rational
Tyler picked that out this is our fourth
podcast fourth I believe so we did two
this week so we basically doubled our
podcast episodes this week that is
extremely impressive I just there's so
much happening all the time and like we
are here to cover all of it let's we're
gonna thought of it we're just you know
whatever we've got some fun little
things here that you guys requested on
Twitter that we talked about there's
buttons that we can push people don't
push no but what if I push one but you
don't push the one that I don't want you
to push cuz it's so loud in my head oh
alright will not push another one Oh
welcome to same brain Wow what's this
one do that's it oh that's the crickets
the crickets oh my gosh we have are
these art how many reviews to be 186
review it really yes Wow
oh my gosh you guys are so good at
podcasting you keep me entertained and
your positive attitude is amazing it
keep up the good work
hashtag same brain oh my goodness
another one Wow
I forgot to read the last title this is
awesome this title is wow oh my god this
is amazing I listened to one episode and
I was immediately intrigued this is
awesome guys keep it up I will be back
every Saturday to listen to this you
know what oh no I got the wrong whoa oh
there's a clapping you don't want you
seen you know what's fun what rumors
about new tech some rumors yeah Hawks
related Xbox it's the the code name is
Lockhart it's kind of interesting so
obviously you guys know about the Xbox
series X that should be out this holiday
should be I mean it will be out well we
you know you never know I mean I really
don't know I really don't it's affected
it has been announced holiday 2020 which
is just around the corner but yeah there
isn't just around the Riverbend now it's
around the corner around the corner okay
Xbox series one is expected to be an
absolute beast of a console capable of
playing video games 4k 614 second
expected have a one terabyte solid state
drive and like a ton of different specs
here which I feel like a lot of people
already covered this stuff but me and
Jenna are both huge Xbox fans oh yeah
I'm I mean I've been playing so many
video games and Quarantine it's kind of
its kind of crazy animal crossing there
is a summer update and holy moly I'm
incredibly excited but here's the thing
I'm on the southern hemisphere and this
is like a summer you can you start over
I will not doing that so in the new
update you'll be able to swim and dive
and find new so this company actually in
July third it's right after July 2nd
which I have a car appointment oh my
gosh my only plans of 2020 yeah so you
can women swapping and wet suits for the
first time ever at animal crossing
you'll be able to swim in the ocean
surrounding your island using a wetsuit
the sea is yours to explore I hit the
microphone again it's fine
oh my goodness so this article came up
when I was looking for Pokemon go cuz I
feel like they were supposed to relaunch
Pokemon go but do you remember how much
fun we had yes we were walking like 20
miles a day is article its Pokemon go
grandpa please with 64 phones on his
bike look at this picture Jenna I'm
looking at it first offer how do you
have that many phones ok I mean it's how
do you this is the most like I am
jealous because this is what this is how
we need to do phone reviews it basically
looks like a peacock of phones
what does this ox tail like in your
that's insane that's absolutely insane I
can't believe this is the day that I
first listened to BTS well so I've
listened to them but I have no white why
did nobody tell me that they're
incredible in millions and millions and
hundreds of millions of people have been
telling people that they're incredible
but I don't know like so here's this is
I think my problem is like I get super
into stuff so I tried to like avoid
things that I know Mandy he's like super
into you like World of Warcraft cuz I
know that'll probably ruin my life but
like for some reason I just never and I
was like BTS BTS so good and the reason
that I decided to finally oh and listen
to BTS is because Samsung did a
collaboration with BTS for one of their
new phones the s20 plus it looks very
very
like this is a phone that I wanted like
a purplish-pinkish color it's so
greatness hearts on a bail set my buds
as well I believe yes the galaxy buds oh
my gosh couldn't we talk about how good
beaches yes just that's why I've ever
like millions of people like them I
think it's even more than millions what
hundreds of million every hylians
billion so upset that it's taken me this
long this was also something that Tyler
was talking about that he mentioned
would be interesting for us to chat
about about Apple bringing touchscreen
back to the next iPhone because of face
masks please can you do that bloom we do
that I miss and I actually do when I
started using the se I was like wow this
is nice yeah the fingerprint is faster
because I feel like that slight swipe up
is actually it takes more time and if
you just like pick up your phone yeah
and you just you would just pick it up
and touch where you need to be and just
really pixels my favorite oh yeah the
perfect location for your pointer finger
like what if you could do know what you
know it's just something else I feel
like there has to be something else at
someone's iris scanners now because
that's still kind of like face ID type
of thing yeah these glasses are really
hurting my ears
I think the headphones are also hurting
my everything is hurting my I'm gonna
take my headphones option okay yeah
let's take a break
oh I mean I actually have to actively
take off my contacts take them out so
that I can put these glasses on
[Music]